[Musique]
la séquence que nous allons vous
présenter maintenant est en quelque
sorte une expérience que nous avons
voulu faire à savoir l'homme de la rue
est il réellement observateurs pour ce
faire nous avons dissimulé notre caméra
dans notre voiture piège
installé à l'angle de la rue galilée et
de l'avenue marceau jean france l 1 m 85
pardessus sombre et toque de fourrure va
demander son chemin aux passants à
l'aide de deux ouvriers portant un
tableau une grande pancarte un grand
calicots il va disparaître un certain
moment pour faire place à jacques legras
qui n'a pas du tout les mêmes
proportions qui fait lui 1 m 72 qui
n'est pas habillée de la même manière
qu'ils portent un chapeau et des
lunettes
les gens interrogent et ventilent
s'apercevoir de la substitution des
personnages c'est ce que nous allons
savoir immédiatement
pardon monsieur s'il vous plaît plus
beau en sueur 16e arrondissement près
tous les frères réthoré faible encore
oui oui
de prouver qu'elle a amené la home c'est
pas par là alors c'est pas pour déjà les
ou abus vienna d'abord il ne traîne sous
l'effet des vibrations à l'abus guéna
vous traversez vous arrivez à l'avenue
kléber kléber oui je n'ai la recrue ben
oui vous descendez l'avenue kléber vers
la tour eiffel et vous trouverez la rue
poirier guy boissière 16e alors même si
beaucoup d'amour
m
oui monsieur
[Musique]
dans le 16e arrondissement n'est pas
parce que je ne suis pas français total
et pourquoi
[Rires]
c'est par là alors je rendez vous ici je
dois partie vous dit tout c'est à peu
près à peut-être par l'attendait à on
merci oui
on se demandera beaucoup ri
[Musique]
dites moi vous trouvez rien de rien
normal vous ne trouvez rien de normal
oui je le revois ciel c'est moi qui vous
ai demandé n'est ce pas où était la rue
voisine
mais pourquoi mais mon cher monsieur
alors écoutez vous allez très bientôt
non mais je voulais vous êtes la
reconduire juste moi vous êtes bien sûr
que c'est moi qui vous ai demandé la rue
boissière si vous êtes sûr que ça
[Musique]
vous auriez vous soyez c'est très bien
si pour la caméra est solide
c'est pour la caméra sony vous êtes
filmés étude les redresseurs
après un tour eiffel 16e arrondissement
mois bruce glaciaire boissière à sierre
oui portable wii one on one brassière
résolu boissieu près de rue bois sueur
le prêtre fr 16e arrondissement
ouah pour grandi je me passerais bien
parler français n'est ce pas au rugby
heures près tous les fans
[Musique]
[Rires]
avenue marceau omar sow
[Musique]
monsieur j'ai trouvé ton boss 16e
arrondissement ici oui très bien madame
ne vous en avez pas surtout rester
madame caméra insolite c'est un test
psychologique venez madame car vous
venez d'assister une expérience madame
c'est la radio télévision française avec
de très bien pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
qu'est ce qu'il ya vu qu est-ce qu à lui
qu'est ce qui vous a paru bizarre et
celles à rester là 10 et 20 heures
papa roger mais non pourquoi
car nous sommes filmés en permanence
nous avons recommencé l'expérience une
dizaine de fois et en tout et pour tout
une dame une seule dame s'est aperçue de
la substitution encore cette dame quand
nous lui avons demandé par quel
subterfuge ses personnages avec il
changé nous a répondu j'ai pensé qu'il y
avait une trappe qui était pratiqué dans
le trottoir
vous vous souvenez tous du sketch de
fernand raynaud qui s'intitulait les
croissants dans ce sketch un monsieur
s'obstinait à demander un garçon de café
des croissants que ce garçon de café ne
possédait pas eh bien nous avons repris
ce principe en essayant de mettre en
valeur la gentillesse et la patience on
verbial du commerçant français
nous avons changé le café nous avons
fait une boutique de fleuriste les
croissants sont devenus des camélias et
fernand raynaud lui même a accepté de
rejouer son sketch dans la vie la voix
un petit peu maquillée nous lui avons
mis une moustache nous l'avons affublé
d'une casquette et d'une blouse de
livreurs et vous allez voir ce que ça va
donner
pour aider des petits fera avoir poussé
des babys aux âges un peu
vous avez des camélias vous êtes et
comédien johnny
c'est de la chasse j'ai pas de 2
milliards
c'est trop cher
on m'a nommé parler des petites d'eptica
milliards
on ne veut pas de moi
une fin d'année mais s'était croire à
des animaux quand égard aux affronts 50
alors qu'elle était plus jolie à rome
alors comment c'est une fille je ne te
tue c'est pour offrir c'est pour vous
l'offrir à quelqu'un
oui mais voilà mais j'ai pas mal de
savoir si vous voulez quoi sans cesse
mais pour des tulipes ça c'est des
tulipes hollandaises
alors donnez moi une bonne technique
floride et caméras je suis pas de
comédien je n'ai pas de camille rien
j'ai des tulipes la trace d'une hypnose
est très belle et des idées s'est
déroulé ses actuels et oui pour moi dit
il est alors ben salah vous ne vous en
rendez vous avec des caméras comme ça
coûte ça ça vaut 250 de concert
car oui ce départ comme camélia je ne
nie pas alors maintenant des mois alors
devenu communiste pour les essais fleurs
jaunes l'a pas dupes les ja comment mais
il ya des motifs régie alors bon gars
mais au milieu
[Rires]
comment
donnez moi ça alors comme ça tout ça
quatre en quatre 4 ans oui camélia au
mieux je sais pas ce qu'il ya à voir la
différence je vous dis que j'ai pas mal
d'autres choses
le franc de frein non 9 9,5 et 4,9 à
naucelle sont des camélias ça non
c'était tunis
c'est des tulipes hollandaises
hollandaise hollandais ses traits vous
offrir vous voulez ça voudra mais au
mieux
jeudi le porte parole alors j'ai marié
alors donnez moi ce bourdonner masque
vous avais je pas vous embêter des
masques ou mai
camélia
à nous d'aller les comédiens comment ce
n'est pas la saison mais de démarches
que vous avez trois superbes et en droit
commun
[Musique]
oui mais alors au revoir et à l'art mais
que vous allez donner à la dame ça se
fera avec un billet maintenant oui mais
en rien vous ayez le camélia je vous dis
je n'ai pas avant alors donnez moi en
étant donné que camille alors le type
roumajon payer moi je dis pas ce que je
sais moi et m'a alors donné moi ça alors
les par bonheur avec amelia et vous avez
dit que l'on m'avait dit c'est la cena
nous y dit justement ça n'est pas la
saison du canadien avant c'est pas la
serbie mais ça c'est très jeune et on ne
voit rien que tu vois je viens vous le
payez mais vouloir vendre leur papier
n'est fait avant sans avoir jamais rien
pourquoi je veux payer je suis bon je
suis par messages comme un fils à papa
et maman
[Musique]
qu'est ce que la ville natale où les
fans de camélia que la semaine je lui
dis que nous n'avons pas avant voyez
vous si sûr nous ne vous avons alors bon
mais ça coûte cher ce sont des camélias
armée jour à 9h la phrase oui avec
amelio mieux c'est du belge philippe
jobin bêta mais nous amuser vagin virage
vous et des fleurs mais si je vis des
camélias nôtre je vous aurais dit j'en
ai et je garde la balle énorme et cela
durera encore quelques minutes cette
dame va-t-elle finir par se fâcher
assistons à la suite des événements
guéant jose h deux femmes aiment à nous
l'achète et banon le plan et vous l'avez
et les voilà mais donnez moi mon cas
mais a agi non et je vous ai dit je n'ai
pas de camédia on n'a pas de camélia non
et alors vous avez dit oui à la vie à la
dame à l'année 2010 si j'en avais eu m
si j'en avais eu d'agenda les murs eh
bien il ya longtemps que je vous aurais
dit j'en ai et je vais vous en vendre
mais je ne n'ai pas écouté madame
communistes français et jeunes s
comprend le français
bon je vous dirais même mieux si vous
êtes très gentil et ben alors c'est que
et je suis pas sûr c'est la caméra un
solide tout de suite je me présente
fernand raynaud
vous êtes formidable parce que vous avez
gardé patient jusqu'à la fin c'est
extraordinaire de ce terminal madame et
je vous acheter et vous violette et vos
camélia et botulique 2012 avoir cette
formidable c'est la caméra se lit bravo
aux états menacés
vous pouvez décider de la passion et moi
m'excuser c'est ça que je voulais c'est
un monsieur oui il y avait la télévision
qui vous filmer en même temps la
séquence que vous allez voir maintenant
s'est déroulée dans ce café la caméra
était dissimulée derrière l'étagère à
bouteilles jacques legras au comptoir
jacques legras qui joue le personnage du
patron de monsieur emile va vendre à des
comédiens compères des billets de 1000
francs 2000 francs anciens mais tenez
vous bien il va les vendre ses billets
pour la somme exorbitante de 500 francs
c'est à dire exactement à moitié prix je
précise pour la bonne compréhension de
la séquence qu'il ne vend que des
billets nouveau à l'éffigie de voltaire
prétexte la banque de france veut faire
de la publicité pour ses billets parce
que les gens les gens ne viennent pas
tellement les gens sont un peu rebuté
par ses billets et la banque de france a
décidé de faire une campagne de
publicité au bar au comptoir
vous allez voir un monsieur qui est un
fournisseur de la maison et qui ignore
tout encore de la scène dont il va être
le témoin
comment va-t-il réagir devant cette
vente insolite c'est ce que la caméra
invisible va nous dire immédiatement
madame se demandait à un petit service
je suis très embêté j'ai un ami de
régiment qui a mis de bourges qui vient
de débarquer à paris vous savez il veut
absolument que je passe la journée avec
lui
les fasse voir les monuments qu'on aille
dans les boîtes de nuit au moins ça ne
m'intéresse pas je suis mariée et je
suis vraiment que je ne sais pas comment
m'en défaire
alors vous voyez moi d'un service et par
exemple je lui dirai que je viens de
rencontrer ma tante
j'ai rencontré ma tante jeanne et qui me
demande d'aller chez elle on s'est pas
vu depuis très tôt grand s'est pas vu
depuis très longtemps et elle aimerait
que j'allais chez elle un petit peu et à
cause de ça je ne peux pas aller
victoire
alors ils entendent téléphonie va pas
tarder sûrement on peut on peut se
tutoyer sa phrase c'est un peuple aussi
venue jusqu'à moi je croise assez mais
très bien partout dit il va il va pas
tarder maintenant assorti à ses papiers
au gabon c'est pas libre je suis navré
je présente ma tante toujours mal à ces
marchands jihadjane abrité du tout il ya
lieu de la rencontre
je ne pourrai pas aller avec toi
malheureusement parce que je suis obligé
d'aller chez matin qui m'a pas vu depuis
longtemps
je n'ai jamais leur est venue de nice
peut être là ce soir à 5 heures ils ont
été aux folies bergères petite blonde
l'indonésie
non la grande oui non non c est
malheureusement je ne pourrai pas tu
vois qu'est ce que tu en penses
maintenant tu as muse s'est pas vu ça
fait combien avancé pas vu non ça fait
cinq ans vous avez emprunté au moins
deux mois je n'avais pas reconnu
puis passer à côté j'ai puis ça me dit
tiens jacques est ce que tu fais là
ah oui comment va-t-on henry qui va bien
ben oui fatalement moi j'ai pas eu ici
que j'écris pas facilement
vous voyez pas souvent alors ben non oui
ça fait je sais pas combien se fait bien
deux ans pensait pas vu non plus que ça
hein c'est bien ce qui me semblait ah
oui et comment va chi chi le petit chien
il va bien toujours comme ça ah bon
qu'est-ce qu'il va pas tourner ma faim
tout ne va pas c'est pourquoi je deviens
vite au duras ça on écoute pas dit
d'enfourner à y passer parce que je ne
l'étais pas reconnu mais pourquoi je
veux pas pourquoi je suis obligé oui
mais alors on fait 30 à combien de temps
vous me l'apprenez
regarde-moi longtemps toute la zone et
oui cela ce rythme on a des rendez-vous
alors tu sais sur la pâte ou des
commandes et maintenant ainsi ainsi
malheureusement tu vois vous habitez
loin dhr assez loin on a bossé abassi
torride mais je pourrais pas resté
longtemps aussi ça je pourrais pas
rester longtemps
il faut se veut rester avec vous une
heure ou deux par la non malheureusement
on ne peut pas non plus on ne peut pas
venir parce que vous déjeunez ensemble
oui bon ça ne peut pas venir autrement
c'est avec plaisir à beaucoup de moi je
vais chercher un bifteck et pour un
message
et si je fais les choses avant non comme
ça faisait plaisir de rencontrer sa
grille
une autre formule aujourd'hui je vais
faire demain à bourges une autre fois
que tu reviendras paris mais pour
l'instant on ne peut pas d'ailleurs si
tu sais chercher dans jones est très
jolie et très simple c'est il n'y a pas
suffisamment de place non non ça ouvre
des jackets 3 5
alors oui s'est déclaré non je sais les
p'tits loulous tout ça c'est un vrai
talent après ce conflit
et bien qu'ils allaient jouer avec toi
maintenant il a vraiment vieux chais
obligé de te quitter je vais te couper
mais non non non non tu sais pas ce que
j'ai parlé avec tandja on a un tas de
choses à se dire très important pour moi
j'irai le chercher c'est ça passe
aujourd'hui non aller chercher dans
lequel tu me rappelles ce soir là et non
je ne peux pas pour s'arrêter six ans
quand j'en ai parlé des projets vitaux
restaurant si vous laissez pas cette
question là on a des choses à se dire
dans la poule a c'est le début oui je
comprends ça il allait la cousine
germaine comment va-t-elle un premier
elle va bien ces enfants aussi tout le
monde va bien
ah bon je me sens bien je te vois plus
tard titre à petit mois madame oui on
peut enfin le territoire
je voulais vous dire que vous gardez
vous gardez ce que oui à ce soir-là
entendu vous serez vous souriez c'est
très gentil de votre part un prix parce
que vous êtes dans la caméra inscrits
pour la télévision française et vous
êtes filmés actuellement oui
vous aussi savez-vous et la caméra et
bien vous avez divisés vous êtes
vraiment très gentils et celle venez
nous voir inviter celles mais des sales
bêtes de scène
vous avez fait très mal mais un mensonge
depuis jeudi enfin valeria moi j'ai
gueulé je vis maintenant mais ça le fait
comment ça va te laver manger alors
viens de prolonger la magie un an je
pense qu'on a camera solide comme vous
voyez vous êtes rentré grand plaisir non
nous avons encore beaucoup à travailler
[Musique]